We've been working with quadratic inequalities and clearly linear inequalities
before that, but a lot of the techniques that we've learned to use can actually
be used in a number of other kinds of situations too. Now we're going to take a
second to talk about rational inequalities, which are things like this, for
example. The quantity 2x minus 18 divided by the quantity x minus 4 is greater
than or equal to 0. The reason this is called a rational inequality is because
the left side over here is an example of a rational expression. Remember when we
talked about rational numbers early Julie pointed out that the word ratio is
inside the word rational. So while a rational number is just the ratio of 2
integers. We will remember the denominator is not allowed to be 0, and rational
expression seems to be pretty closely related. It's just the ratio of two
polynomials. And like with rational numbers, the denominator is not equal to
zero.